[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
or we talk about whatever we won't how
does it go after that that's like
[ __ ] people's coordinators like a low
simmer yeah
people's corn I don't know I bought that
one judge I think he's just a guy
talking right it's like this is Judge
Judy Scheindlin she's the most badass
like you know I love about those
people's court [ __ ] though
you could always guarantee every guy
walks in with an oversized shirt and
oversized dress yes
I think for some reason they don't know
how to find some that fits them yeah and
it's always like a fold coming right
down dress shirts like neck is way too
big so it's always down here and there
tuck it ties drag guys ever buy the
dresser and tie in a pack yep oh yeah I
couldn't when you're when you're broken
II but you still have to look good yeah
it's like $8.99 and it's a tie and a
dress shirt already together in a
plastic thing wondering why nobody else
knew about this [ __ ]
yeah what a deal until you put on the
shirt and then you're a wife beater it's
like this you could see through it you
can see what the hell's work you're
wearing underneath are you see your
nipple color yeah yeah when I saw men
and I could see their nipples on like
opera that's why I think he's birthday
thing
and I was taken you guys know the video
where that we've all watched where
snakes are all waiting as these lizards
have yeah so that's what going to this
[ __ ] Club was like like for Nicky's
birthday like we kind of came with like
three girls and every dude at the whole
joint was just like constantly like was
it a sausage fest yeah well yeah
absolutely it always is but you know why
though right
one cuz the girls are [ __ ] hot yeah
well no I know but dude it was like
agreed just right like Nikki was walking
right so you're just walking in front
and ahead of me
and this guy takes her harm like this he
doesn't go [ __ ] yes and he starts
dancing like this yeah not like [ __ ]
armed clock this fool be like yo dude
now she's with me a man like that it was
like that that's what the wedding bands
like supposed to be for the off limits
or was she walking like this so Nikki
our friend Justin V they were they were
all walking through a crosswalk I'm
married I married a man like this like
things like they were holding their
hands up I got a hostage situation and
me and me I watch these dudes were like
so like you need a friend yeah oh it
doesn't matter like it was how far away
were you walking with them depend
depends on you in the group I was in the
group yeah well they were they would
like walk towards the bar right and then
that's when they would get Acosta's when
I haven't been into like a club Club and
so long I forgot what that was well it's
not a good feeling dude actually it's
super nervous I feel like I have to
stick my dick out have it hard and have
it like touching people when I'm in the
club like stay away
hey wait it is like that it's the most
tribal experience because that's what
guys are afraid of the dick so like if
I'm with a group of girls that I need to
like be the protector and be outside
with my dick just waving around yeah and
they don't want to look this way this
whole time so you have to explain it
right you guys get it cuz I'm a girl no
so you could be like the hottest group
of girls right you can have [ __ ]
Ronnie Coleman right there the most jack
dude in the world
[ __ ] former mr. Allnut be alright of
course there's still gonna be a dude
that's like I'm a [ __ ] challenges for
I don't give a [ __ ] yes but if you have
a dude with the rock-hard [ __ ] dick
ready the buzz single person know
everyone and then the dicks out then no
one oh [ __ ] no especially if he's like
I'm about to [ __ ] yeah yeah y'all got the
bus everywhere [ __ ] back
bro yeah I will [ __ ] bus
hostage situations like they should they
really should or did we talk about it I
can I made up scenario well Dave
Chappelle has a bit where there's a
homeless man that takes the bus hostage
by jacking off that's the best repellent
like if you go to the club and you don't
know if you could fend off all the dudes
go pantsless and just just walk around
like a baby with shoes and [ __ ] a
t-shirt truth babies wear diapers Joe
you always forget that part they wear
diapers do you think of the Tom Cruise
risky business outfit yes some babies at
home just don't have any diapers on the
rice farms of Japan do those babies put
around butt naked yep they just bet that
ding glaring ding-a-ling just dangling
down Bingle ear dangling it one of those
things where it's like why are we here
this this is not that fun cuz that sucks
cuz girls want to go and dance and guys
want to go and dance too but then you
have those [ __ ] thirsty [ __ ]
correct one thing I don't understand
like if girls want to dance why don't
they just tell all the girlfriends to
come home dancing living I mean we all
like the way music sounds and feels you
want to hear that big base and you want
everyone to be dancing why you got it
look so good while doing it we can't
help it you know to me like nobody and
like if it's time how do you tell the
time minute stop shining you can't no
but that that's the that's the weird
thing because if you turn the lights off
if you're if you're gonna throw this
orange at her like certainly I gripped
it really hard I was like but if you're
trying to dance right like wearing heels
short things that's not very comfortable
to dance in well I mean why can't we
just look good thank you
right you can I'm just saying that it
doesn't make any sense to me because if
I want to dance comfortably I'm not
gonna go there with uncomfortable
clothes high heels and all that stand
then complain about the situation that
they're exactly and then you get the
extra attention because y'all look is so
sexy my high heels make your legs look
real good
but I know now you're saying that guys
can't control themselves no no what I
guess what I'm saying is don't mind the
attention it's the [ __ ] the extra
steps beyond do you want this it's an
ego boost do you want the attention is
that why they want the whole world to
watch while their dads want the attend
why would you trust like that if you
don't yeah but it's not like they don't
want the attention for everybody they
want the attention from you that yeah
that and then I mean you just want to
feel hot okay coming guys I'll just go
to my can just do you guys wanna dance
the bunch of dance is that that's not a
club atmosphere I think well that's the
conflict that I don't quite understand
is because you want to feel hot but the
what happens when you feel hot and you
look hot is people are attracted to you
and they're gonna be trying to get you
sure right but there's different ways
that they can do that I think it's once
they pass that like that like oh no I'm
with so-and-so it's like okay cool and
they're respect when they back off like
no girls complaining about hopefully oh
but that's what I'm saying I'm
complaining about the guys being agreed
just dude they're [ __ ] bananas what
everyone's complaining yeah but these
guys are shaming all y'all and being
like oh well you dressing like that so
you deserve it and I think that's wrong
that's not what I'm saying complaining
about the attention yeah what I'm saying
it's that tension point no we're
complaining about the egregious part yes
oh guy here and females that's a world
too like I agree that thirst monger is
crazy like that doesn't matter how we're
dressing it's like you should just be
respectful also with those club
situations too there's the half that
don't like it like you guys but there's
the other half of girls that really do
like it so it's like it's they do like
that 10 yes so it's still a place where
some people are still getting what they
want you know maybe like the attention
they like it that's cool so funny window
is a girl who is like maybe a three and
then she would go around and act like
she's the hottest [ __ ] on earth because
there's so many guys that are thirsty as
[ __ ] so then they get an ego boost and
I'm watching the whole thing go down and
I'm like dude this this is [ __ ] this
is the aquarium dude this is party it's
five like madam you are gargoyle excuse
me
you got the confidence yeah I still
think that's badass is [ __ ] though
it's pretty bad at it also sucks when
that girl mistreats all the dudes around
them because she thinks that she's as
hot as the other it's it's funny I just
think it's like it's like hey can I buy
you a drink ah yeah no we're taking me
talking to you well you're a good thing
about this the other good thing about
this [ __ ] is like PI sixty percent of
the guys there have all read the art of
the pickup and I'll show ya oh I
guarantee the type no no the tapes that
go to club because they're like socially
awkward they never dated before they
don't know any of that stuff and they're
practicing there yeah and it's just the
situation where it's it's so weird cuz
everyone's acting exactly and they watch
the videos of like guys on YouTube who
break down interviews that like craig
ferguson's had with Scarlett Johansson
it's like oh he's secretly I [ __ ] her
and she's really into it and like she is
definitely get it getting her like from
this interview and I'm like they read
into every little thing where it's like
he compliment he taps her shoulder real
quick and it's like now he's established
like connection or dude it's [ __ ]
hilarious they watching a swarm of those
guys like come in and surround girls and
try to do it it's I don't know like just
watching the whole thing go down is the
funniest thing on earth it's so funny to
me I can't stop watching a probability
game though cuz it's like some of those
dudes though they'll shoot this shot
like thirty times but somebody's gonna
bite you know and that's really that's
what it is I think that's what for me
like going clubbing it's kind of a weird
place where like I already know all
these thirst mongering dudes are there
and it's almost kind of like what do you
expect if you bring a 12 inch sub into
the middle of Skid Row you know what I
mean it's like you're gonna get [ __ ]
bum ball crack rock yeah I like since
the $5 footlong they're pretty
affordable yeah okay
by the middle woody I've seen homeless
guys with 12 inch subs because you got
dudes waiting [ __ ] books like that
guys that are like just still trying to
figure out what's the best pick-up line
they still aren't thinking they're
thinking like the most dumbest [ __ ] ever
and so now you have girls going there
looking super hot of course you're gonna
have it es that are acting too stupid in
there in a perfect world Oh like I wish
we can just go to enjoy music in dance
and there's a even number of people and
it's not too crowded and it's not full
of [ __ ] idiots but married people's
Club I don't feel like defender at tens
riding like a [ __ ] I don't like
weddings it depends on the age that you
get go to a wedding too because if it's
a younger person's wedding and you're
single that is kind of like a club
scenario too or if it's ghetto as [ __ ]
there's always a fight that goes down
during the reception cuz when I cuz when
I was single and then you get invited to
these weddings it was it would suck when
I went to these weddings and most of
them were with somebody cuz it was it
would be nice if they were some people
around we were single because then it
would decide you want David I don't know
what happened here it depends oh my god
I feel like I do like Vegas clubs when
it's not crazy crowded when is that yeah
when is not a Wednesday night I mean
we've been we've been remember when we
when we went a long time ago during the
week instead of the weekend and then we
got like a table and all that stuff it
wasn't crowded but there was a good
amount of people I will say no matter
what night
karaoke at the circus circus there's not
a lot of people there that [ __ ] was fun
that was fun and the clientele was great
because there's a whole bunch of people
from out of town and they're all just
kind of sitting there like like for them
this was where they were going yeah this
was the destination and for us we're
like we're gonna be funny one to Circus
Circus I like [ __ ] around like that
but you're but you're right geo actually
the environment where everyone's looking
good coming coming in to just chill
dance and then like you get a little bit
i candy and you're like oh you look good
like this is awesome but then you still
have your date - that's a lot better
than like these some of these Hollywood
clubs that are just like 90% dudes and
then you're like [ __ ] what did I get
myself into
that's why girls go to gay clubs hah
yeah cuz everyone's having a good time
ain't nobody trying to pick up on you
yeah dudes are feeling [ __ ] with ya
needs to experience a gig I've never
know what it's like I've never but some
of our staff they dance at a gay club
and they've told me like some crazy [ __ ]
they just grab coming like go-go boys
yeah yeah they'll come and grab your
junk or they just like start making out
your ear oh Jesus I've been doing a club
it wasn't like that but but then again
I'm I'm a taller guy so I don't feel
like I was ever like they got a tippy
toe to reach your ear yeah I don't I
didn't feel like I was definitely the
bear Yeah right I didn't feel like I was
gonna be like threatened or like I'm the
carob yeah I don't want I don't want to
go and then like all these dudes come up
on me and then my [ __ ] egos inflated
nadzam ha it's all hot to these dudes
I'm like I'm a cute asian boy I'm a
[ __ ] I'm luscious to them I was a gay
guy watching this right now is like you
wish you had not my time dude Nikki's
walking in front of me in the stairs
just apartment complex and I'm like full
bore like egregiously like if you didn't
know that she's my wife you'd think I'm
the biggest [ __ ] pervert cuz I will I
will do a full tilt like underneath her
dress and do that please I do that he go
what the [ __ ] are you doing I think that
all the time I do that all the [ __ ]
time I go to like show it be wearing
like these shorts at home a [ __ ] tap
in a little dude that's [ __ ] he's
just having fun on my program I doing
practicing my latest it's like you know
how I picture it i 100% agree that you
are doing it but she's probably wearing
a dress and you're going like this
but it was like oh damn what's under
here be like sometimes talk to me about
something serious and [ __ ] and I like
she'll be like upset about something or
whatever video didn't upload and she
feels very stressed out today or
whatever and like as she's doing it I'm
slowly positioning her in front of the
mirror so I could just look at her
butthole and then she's so now she's
kind of caught onto that cuz we've been
do it for a long time so she's like wait
you just putting me in front of the
mirror you just want to look at my butt
well you're just taking off my clothes
right now you know how to make
complaining a lot more enjoyable yeah
well complain like bending over and like
maybe picking up a quarter we go to his
house all these quarters are [ __ ] big
food on the floor Joe what the [ __ ]
abuelo there's a quarter okay what else
what up what about that oh my god that's
horrible don't bend your knees just
don't find out the new I know it just
doesn't really nice that it is that's
why it's hard for me to stay mad at her
for a very long time just got you so try
your damnedest don't you working
overtime grab stay back I try but it's
difficult that was it a little Tokyo the
other day and I saw for the first time
ever a female homeless lady take a piss
in the middle of the street Oh finally
that's me I've never seen a lady I've
seen a dude walk around just slaying it
around but she just sat in the middle of
the street right and she pissed right in
front of me middle I've seen ladies [ __ ]
their brains out okay yeah
my mommy no homeless that's how he's
learning what he's boarding right now
I've seen ladies [ __ ] their brains on
it's like my gosh it's crazy it's crazy
then she just pulled it right down to
start peeing right I was like what I
feel lady do that like right next to a
bench like those bus benches she was
wearing a dress so she just lifted it
like that I'm just like what the [ __ ]
yeah yeah I saw a video on Twitter
yesterday where dude was [ __ ] a
crackhead in the truck bed and the title
was you [ __ ] would literally
[ __ ] anything damn that's true though
crack kid himself no I think he was
paying her yeah [ __ ] her in the back
of a truck man yeah and she was legit a
crackhead nobody was filming yes go he
caught the dude [ __ ] and then he
caught up what oh he got so many nasty
things on his wheel
that [ __ ] was so weird that's weird you
watched the whole thing it was only like
five seconds was on Twitter oh there's
this guy that's in Kansas City or
Oklahoma City or some [ __ ] like that
but he's like this like a like a like a
John catcher so imagine like 20 20 oh
god I've seen this so all he does is he
films guys picking up hookers and then
he he drives up and he says what are you
guys doing stop [ __ ] in the car and
he records the whole thing yeah and it's
really funny so John is someone that
buys a lady yes okay
I saw a version of this but it was it
was similar to that but it was by the
Sheriff's Department and they were like
just they were at like some backwoods
location shitty location and then they
would just run guys through there like
every time a guy would go to pick up a
girl they would just pick him up every
like it was like but they were it was
like a honey pot there's so many though
it's crazy like it's like throughout the
day this guy would just keep catching
them all day long and every time dude
every time that they busted these cats
these kids are always like it's like oh
I'm just
oh no I'm just here I just wanted to
talk to her the lies are fighting it so
a lot of them big they're like they're
like they're trying to like read the
Bible to them or like girl I was just
like I'm just trying to convert her and
change your life it's like so we got
your pack
down set the [ __ ] that's like what they
used to do in the Chris Hanson show to
where it's like I'm just here to talk to
the child I just wanted to speak with
the child and it's like Jesus dude
condoms in a spot yeah right so why do
you have condoms and beer and he's like
well I just happened to procure condoms
they always use some bigger word than
there usually is yeah I always thought
that was weird - it's like dude you're a
[ __ ] scumbag why do you have condoms
I think that's just one moral thing it's
like you know what the [ __ ] is through
your old blood hey I'm protected but I
have these latex gloves on
[Music]